cyril jusqu'à lierse était très inquiet
par rapport à l'élection présidentielle
2022 mais grâce à ton invité j'ai appris
qu'il n'y avait pas d'élection en
élection cameroon and l'année prochaine
où il rage universel elle aura lieu
ouais mais je pense quelle va être la
seule peut-être pensé vous pensez quoi
moi je pense très clairement
qu'aujourd'hui
d'abord un ils gagnent du temps 2 comme
les régionales les rasets repoussé donc
c'est pas lui qui va annoncer parce que
ce serait la révolution que les
élections n'auront pas lieu
c'est l'europe qui va dire écouter
vraiment les conditions ne sont pas
riches mais voilà comme ça c'est clair
donc message à tous les candidats
pas la peine de vous endetter pour faire
une campagne
il est à deux doigts de nous dire vous
savez que la pluie c'est un complot des
fabricants le parapluie hier cette
émission c'est la quatrième dimension
car on a découvert aussi que des
influenceurs été payé pour dire du mal
des vaccins aux influenceurs et 10 et
fidea est français aurait été approché
par une entreprise de communication afin
de diffuser de fausses informations sur
le vaccin de pfizer dans le but de le
dénigrer une affaire qui aurait pu avoir
de lourdes conséquences qu'ils n'avaient
pas alerté sur la situation
alors faut-il condamner l'agente de
communication je vous dis aussi les
suppositions doussain ne viendrez vous
verrez c'est incroyable parce qu'on
assiste à une véritable guerre des labos
on à jérémy alias docteur jfk kate avec
no mercy est là très heureux voilà
docteur g 20 qui n'est ni docteur ni gfk
comme ça c'est réglé mais qui est très
sympa c'est fou d'être payé pour
dénigrer des trucs c'est le nouveau
monde ça par exemple guillaume genton en
venant habillée comme ça dénigre une
marque tous les jours
gilbert des appareils il est libre tous
les jours un coiffeur moi pareil pour
les régimes n'y a pas que les influencer
sur les réseaux il ya aussi les haters
voulez vous dire que tous les gens ici
qui font cette émission ne sont pas en
bois et il y un phénomène qui s'appelle
haters et nous avons décidé de le
décrypter avec des spécialistes façon
art et voici tma
s'il est un groupe aux people vous
spence et en touraine soldes damart
people there is one of the working in
the world with spanish flou 1-2
pantashop dit acer inc mascarte machine
vie il masque single meet bruder
bogdanov alspa pagaille vers clyde est
dit et ans hyde ses personnels tibi
round name like king of the world 77
dans alcon mcleod de chalon sur saône
bête it makes no thanks because the king
of the world dazong lives in the 77 10 à
16 zink agressive vis catherine resic
radson résine pertes rugueux riches
ainsi qu'à cannes fort allen a offert
huit heures on est femme au calme
vivez hagen hymne france aux irish micky
friends est professeur ahmed aziz omar
da fonseca from the university of the
middle
tell me something for interesting estadi
longue look times haters thousands of
realtors irad discret jeune all of them
after beach resort one ok nom et vous
donner son but à 20h10 frag east faro
faro ma résidence mind theory east here
lies beneath triste hysice au défi à ce
qu'ils me in the truth will be still be
alive in teigneuse my hands with you
because he is coming beach of sound j
[Musique]
damien damian ça va merci d'amener à
d'abord été avec nous rien merci aux
gens très mal pas ici le téléphone on
vient d'un bien de l'avoir on est désolé
c'est vrai qu'il ya des mecs qui font
des duplex dans l'espace non un coup de
fil on n'arrive pas à le donner un
c'est ça la force de l'émission droit
commercial mais la tâche s'avère souvent
terribles merci merci monsieur